I was actually emailed by some
numberphile viewers young sang-gyu and
Gockel rajeev they've been doing it
projects about cutting your fingernails
and they sent it to me and there was
some pretty cool maths in there which
I've sort of developed don't be nice to
talk about what we're gonna talk about
here is what happens when you cut them
with a pair of scissors
you know you might is this gonna freak
you out so I got a cut like that so I
cut from the bottom there and I you you
probably would try to cut to the top
right and then you'd do another one like
that alright and then and then I would
cut across the top like that and then
you can go right fly it off to let's
draw a picture of our anger Nelson well
joy it's a semi-circle Magic's got
radius one
so the first cut well we cut out a
triangle right this is a 45-degree angle
so next cuts so you don't want a big
pointy fingernail it's cut across the
top in such a way that each new side
that we create they're all the same
length do that again we do another cuts
the idea being that we're now got four
sides and that these are all the same
length and of course if I do this enough
times it's going to start looking like
an arc of a circle okay and that's your
goal that's where you want to end up up
right because you don't we yeah you
don't want stabby fingers nails right
you want a nice smooth beautiful
fingernails so you want to reach a
circle so we do that by doing successive
polygons essentially so you could carry
on with this ad infinitum now assuming
you've got an infinite amount of time
after a hundred cuts gonna definitely
look like a circle okay now the question
is how big is this circle because we
never cut at this point again after the
first cuts these angles here are still
gonna be 45 degrees and that's very
important that tells us a lot so I'm now
going to draw a line there which is a
right angle to this new circle that I've
created here and I'm gonna do another
one coming from this point on the circle
again at right angles now what does this
tell me because this is hitting the
tangent to the circle a right angle this
is actually a radius of the new circle
so I can kind of complete the new circle
the other thing I noticed for this point
here whilst it's also the center of the
big circle it's also the bottom of the
top circle that's because of something
that you know about circles is that if
you take two points diametrically
opposite and you connect them via any
point on the circumference they will
meet in 90 degrees so you know the
picture
from this we can very easily work out
how much we've cut off our original
circle had radius of one a little bit of
Pythagoras tells you that this line here
is route to from there to there is route
to from there to there is one so from
there to there is root 2 minus 1 so now
we can compare the ratio between the
size of our nail before to the size of
the nail afterwards they're sort of
height before a call hates before h
after h before was 1 h after is root 2
minus 1 and it's not too difficult to
show that this is the same as root 2
plus 1 well big deal what's so good
about that by cut my fingernails so the
the rank one I had before was bigger
than the one I have after by a factor of
the silver ratio that's what so the
silver ratio is there okay so what is
the silver a shoe you know about the
golden ratio right so golden ratio you
think about with the Fibonacci sequence
okay that's one way of understanding
where the golden ratio comes from so you
start off with zero and one and then you
add these two together and you get one
and then you add these two together and
you get two these two together you get
three these two together you get five
carry on like that that gives you the
Fibonacci sequence their ratio between
terms and there's Fibonacci sequence
tends towards the golden ratio so the
silver ratio is slightly different so
you start off at the same point zero and
one you double this and you add that
gives you two double this and add that
so that's now four plus one is five
double this and add that so that's 12
double this and add that that's gonna
give me 29 and I carry on like that with
that pattern if I want to write down
what that pan is it's like this if he
and is 2 P n minus 1 plus P n minus 2 so
in other words I take the 1 before I
double it and then I add the one before
that you can see this ratio between
consecutive ones will tend to the silver
ratio so you do it the same way as you
derive the golden ratio so I just take
this expression here and I divide
through by PN minus 1 so that gives me P
n divided by PN minus 1 is 2 plus P and
minus 2 over e n minus 1 so at large n
this ratio becomes what I'm going to
call Delta R s this is 2
this is 1 over the ratio that's 1 over
Delta s and if you solve that equation
you get root 2 plus 1 okay so that's the
silver ratio so there is an entire
family of these guys and they're called
the metallic creatures this is the pal
sequence actually there's some fun facts
about this if the pail number is prime
its index is prime okay like it's
positioned yeah yeah exactly its
position is prime we'll call this p2
okay so this is the second pair number
not count in zero we'll call this one p3
okay so you can see that this is a prime
and this is prime this is prime and this
is pro this one here is also a prime
number and yet surprise surprise it's
the fifth power number which is also
prone so has this called property that
if the pal number is prime its index is
prime the other weird property of this
sequence is it contains very few powers
of anything so but by that I mean you
know does it contain squares or cubes or
fourth powers well very few actually the
only ones it contains in the sequence
are 0 1 Java C power 169 is in there
okay which is obviously 13 squared there
we know others there are no fourth
powers there are no other squares there
are no other 26th powers not fit that's
it
this PAL sequence gives you the silver
ratio there are of course
generalizations of this that give you
the other metallic ratio so you've got
the three Bonacci sequence it's 0 1 3 10
30 309 you got starts off with these two
you take this one multiply it by 3 and
add this take this one multiply it by 3
and add this take this one multiply it
by 3 and add this right and you go on
like that
so this is the Fibonacci sequence
multiplying by 1 and adding the 1 yes
yes and all the other metallic ratios
come from multiplying by a different
number I thought it seemed arbitrary but
I hadn't thought of the Fibonacci
sequence as fitting this but it does fit
yeah absolutely absolutely so in general
you can think about sort of n Bonacci
sequence which would have the rule PN is
n PN minus 1 plus PN minus 2 so you take
one of the numbers you multiply it by n
you add
one before that gives you your new
number so this one give you the bronze
ratio n equals four n equals five they
don't have to really have names so I
think some people call it copper nickel
but I think we're free to call them what
we like actually so the bronze ratio
which we'll call Delta P we limited the
ratio of these terms
that's three plus root 13 / - okay all
right which is roughly three point six
yeah but they're not right because you
can think about what you get from the
nth one
okay the nth one the ratio that you
would associate with that I'll call it
Delta N and that is n plus the square
root of n squared plus four over two and
you get that just by applying the same
method as we did for the silver ratio
here everything you think about the
golden ratio will generally have an
analogue here so you can talk about
golden rectangles you can talk about
silver rectangles bronze rectangles you
can talk about golden spirals you can
talk about silver spirals bronze spirals
so you know so what are their properties
okay so it probably needs some more
favor so the golden rectangle is the
follow so you take a rectangle okay and
its sides have the ratio of the golden
ratio so if this one's got length one
this one will have length the golden
ratio which is one plus root 5 over 2
right I really suspect it's not even a
rectangle look at the stage if this were
really a golden rectangle what property
would it have if I remove the largest
square then what's left over would be
another golden rectangle basically 1
over 5 minus 1 is actually equal to
what's the silver version of this we
draw a rectangle whose sides have ratio
given by the silver a ship removed two
large squares both of side 1 and what we
have left over is going to be another
silver rectangle if you did it with the
rectangular whose sides we're in the
bronze ratio you'd have to remove three
and then you'd get one leftover which
was another bronze rectangle in England
of course we have a four paper now you
may know something about a4 paper that
the ratio between the lengths of the
sides is root 2 if this is 1 this would
be root 2 this is another kind of
rectangle actually another kind of
interesting one it's not just a 4 this
is sometimes also called
a silver rectangle but it's not our
silver rectangle so we're not going to
call it silver rectum because some
people would call a route to the silver
ratio actually we're going to call it
the Japanese ratio because it is big in
Japan this ratio this would this route
to and these what I'm going to call a
Japanese rectangle you know lots of
Japanese architecture uses this
particular ratio and these particular
rectangles you also see in Roman altars
all these sorts of things but we're
interested in the real silver ratio so
how would you create it from this guy
you would just remove the largest square
kind of a provillus feels like origami
and you know talk about a Japanese
rectangle so this would be the largest
square here and if I remove it I'm gonna
do it quite crudely I would set this
this is a silver rectangle yeah April
paper is wrong in America you have to be
in England for this to work well some
other places that have a4 paper but
definitely this can work in England not
necessarily in America so this is a
silver rectangle now if I start removing
two larger squares from this I'll get
all the silver rectangles
ever-decreasing so those are the
rectangles that you can have and is
again there's a whole family of them
that you can talk about but more
interesting than the rectangles of
course and the spirals
okay now the spirals are great because
they're the spirals are the things that
everybody says appear everywhere now
people normally say oh the golden ratio
is everywhere isn't it it's everywhere
because they're talking there about the
spirals but it's not really the golden
spiral that's appearing everywhere it's
all these other ones we starts off with
a square and we draw the circle that
goes between there and there now we
create another square which is a factor
smaller by that ratio we're interested
in so we decrease it by a factor of
Delta okay where Delta's out of the
golden ratio or the silver ratio or the
bronze ratio whichever one you're
interested in and we continue our circle
but now we create another square but we
drop by the ratio again and we continue
our curve around and then we go on again
it's gonna have 1 over delta cubed but
let me go around like this and we create
a spiral if this was the golden ratio
this would be a golden spiral if this
was the silver ratio it's a silver
spiral if it's a bronze bronze ratio
it's a bronze power brother
these are all a family of spirals which
are called logarithmic spirals so what
is there a formula for these spirals so
this particular one I can compare you
know I can think of an angle the angle
that I've gone round so I'm going round
like this they've been changing angles I
can ask how does the distance from the
centre change so the distance from the
centre I'll call our well you can sort
of see that if I if I were to go around
this way I gain a factor of Delta every
time I go around a quarter turn so
actually it turns out that our will go
like Delta 2 over PI beta so 2 over PI
of course is or PI over 2 is of course a
quarter turn in radians ok so this is
the formula for this this spiral it was
PI over 2 I have you bought 2 and PI
because I need to scale it by the better
number of radians okay and this is part
of a larger family the logarithmic
spirals which look like this ok so the
theta times the time Hey
so what is P here P is called the pitch
of the particular spiral that you're
interested in and that's very
characteristic of it
imagine I'm coming along this spiral and
I'm going along this direction call that
alpha and then I could draw a right
angle there and I'll call that P and
that's called the pitch of the spiral
now each spiral has its own pitch okay
so we can write down what the pictures
are for the different spirals that we're
interested in so for the gold for the
golden spiral
the pitch is actually you can show it's
about 17 degrees you can work out by
comparing these two formally I'm just
comparing the two you put in the golden
ratio here you can extract what the
pitch is
it works out it's about 17 degrees but a
silver it corresponds the pitch is about
29 degrees for the bronze it's 37
degrees so N equals 4 we get 42 degrees
for N equals 5 we get 46 degrees n
equals 6 49 degrees remember the
Japanese ratio which we said was root 2
that has a picture of about 12 degrees
people always go on all the golden ratio
it's appears everywhere in nature it
does appear in some places in nature but
when they're talking about spirals it's
actually these family of spirals that
appears for example sometimes you'll
hear it said that the Milky Way sees the
golden ratio okay through its spiral
it's not true it does indeed see a
logarithmic spiral with some average
pitch it's about 12 degrees so the milky
way is not a goal
and spiral it's much more like a
Japanese spiral actually there's another
one that I quite like is that Hera groom
Falcons really i love program falcons
are the fastest creature on the planet
you even get them in england right so
there's something cool and animal that
we actually get in England it wins it
Top Trumps as well you know presents the
top storms and my kids ago the program
problems one in the winning one so I
love a peregrine falcon the peregrine
falcon knows about these ratios as well
right imagine you're a peregrine falcon
you're flying around
here's your prey it's sitting here at
the center now you want to keep your
eyes on the prey but you can't move your
eyes you don't wanna start moving your
head around right so yeah that stays in
a fixed position so you have to keep a
fixed angle relative to the prey so that
necessarily means you have to follow one
of these logarithmic spirals the angler
has to look at is actually 40 degrees
which means the pitch of the spiral is
about 50 degrees which is what almost
one of our metallic spirals the I'm
going to call it the N equals six one so
I mean I don't know what this is right
so we've got gold silver bronze copper
nickel aluminum value eight so it's
there right it's pretty much there I
mean it's a good approximation right so
people talk about seashells that they
see the Golden Spiral they don't really
they see a whole all possible pictures
though what they're seeing these
logarithmic spirals and it's a good
reason why why for example seashells see
these these log spirals they have a very
nice property all of them all of them
the golden one the silver one all of
them they kind of have what's called a
self-similar property so you go round
and then you go round again and when you
go round again you're basically seeing a
scaled-down version of exactly the same
thing and you keep seeing that as you go
round and round and round and when you
think about growth in a biological
system that allows you to grow very
efficiently if you follow that pattern
of which is repeated repetition
repetition repetition you also see these
log spirals a lot in architecture and in
art again there's probably a good reason
for that it's related to this self
similar property so basically when you
look at something you know your eye
performs visualizations on lots of
different scales and then correlates
them when you look at this and you look
at it lots of different scales you're
seeing the same thing and so that maybe
there's some sense in which that that's
good because we're correlating a lot of
the same thing on a lot of different
scales reducing
exactly and somehow we like that so this
is why this files appear did you know
you can get numberphile t-shirts there's
a whole range of them most recently
these very special limited edition gold
print ones they look even better in real
life than they do in pictures and as you
can see they're based on videos we've
been posting this week on numberphile if
you'd like to check out all the t-shirts
including the gold ones I'll put a link
down in the video description the gold
ones are actually only available for a
very limited time because we have to
make them to water but either way thanks
for watching we'll see you in the next
video
repetition repetition repetition
repetition repetition repetition well
big deal are so good about